This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可坐时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 TWO。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的对象竟然都是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他罪有应得。我们总说，相信你的好姐妹。听好姐妹的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望过去》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯带来的《艰难成长》。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不安全、但绝对坦诚的对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何操作的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着。你需要收听在 iha 电台应用程序苹果播客或任何你得到的
podcast hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology hello everybody welcome back to the show welcome back to the podcast new listeners old listeners wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course dive into the psychology of our 20s. Today, let's cut to the chase. We're going to be talking about crying.
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要深入探讨二十岁的心理学。今天，咱们开门见山。我们要谈谈哭泣。
It might seem a little bit insignificant to be devoting a whole episode to this. It might seem a bit strange when it comes to our 20s. I think that a lot of us try to avoid crying. But sometimes there is. no better feeling than just having a solid moment to let yourself be in pain, to experience a little bit of self-pity, and to let it all out through tears. And sometimes nothing feels more frustrating than wanting so badly to cry and have that physical outlet for your emotions and being unable to.
把整整一集节目都用来谈论这个，可能显得有点微不足道。对于我们的二十岁来说，这可能也显得有点奇怪。我想我们很多人都尽量避免哭泣。但有时候，没有什么比好好哭上一场，让自己沉浸在痛苦中、体验一点点自怜、并通过眼泪把积压的情绪全部释放出来更好的感觉了。有时候，没有什么比极度渴望哭泣、渴望为情绪找到一个宣泄口却又无能为力更让人沮丧的了。
It can feel like something within us is blocked, something about us is defective, or faulty because we're not feeling things deeply enough or to the point where we can let it all out and have this like physical expression of what is occurring internally. And I really get that. It can leave us with a lot of, I think, frustration and almost like anger at ourselves and just this like longing for a good old fashioned sob. The truth of the matter is our 20s are really freaking hard. Being human is hard. Life is hard. We are all going. to go through difficult moments and times in our lives where we lose people, we're frustrated by life, we're having a really rough time at work, our boss is an asshole, and being able to
这可能会让人觉得我们内心深处有什么东西被堵住了，觉得我们自身有什么缺陷或毛病，因为我们对事物的感受不够深刻，或者还达不到那种能够彻底宣泄、并在内心的发生的事情有一个实体化表达的程度。我真的能理解这一点。我想这会给我们留下许多挫折感，甚至是对自己的愤怒，以及对痛痛快快大哭一场的渴望。事实是，我们的二十岁真的太难了。做人很难。生活很难。我们所有人都要。经历生活中的艰难时刻和时期，我们可能会失去亲人，对生活感到沮丧，在工作中遭遇不顺，老板是个混蛋，而能够
release all that stress, that grief, that anger, that sadness is one of the good parts about being human and having that huge catalogue of emotional expressions and ability to feel emotions. When we feel it. detached from that ability and that happens every now and again. We, I think, feel almost under control, under the control of our emotions. And we feel like there is this pent-up energy inside of us that has nowhere to go, but up and into our brain and cause us more stress and more fear and more anxiety. And tears serve a purpose.
释放所有的压力、悲伤、愤怒和痛苦，是身为人类的美好之处之一，也是拥有庞大情感表达库和感受情感能力的美好之处。当我们感受到。与这种能力脱节，这种情况时有发生。我想，我们会觉得自己几乎失去了控制，被情绪所控制。我们觉得体内有一股郁结的能量无处可去，只能直冲大脑，给我们带来更多的压力、恐惧和焦虑。眼泪是有作用的。
Sometimes they serve as an outlet. that there is nothing better. So for anyone who is feeling a little bit emotionally repressed at the moment, who is finding that they can't even cry in the moments they want nothing more than, that's what we're going to discuss today. We're going to examine some of the reasons psychology and science tells us we need to cry, why we can't cry from emotional suppression to medications or shock, and how we can get back in touch with our big emotions rather than being scared of them.
有时候它们是一个宣泄口。没有什么比这更好的了。因此，对于任何此刻感到情感有些压抑、发现自己在最想哭的时候甚至哭不出来的人，这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。我们将探讨心理学和科学告诉我们需要哭泣的一些原因，为什么我们有时哭不出来（从情感压抑到药物或休克），以及我们如何才能重新与自己的强烈情感建立联系，而不是对它们感到害怕。
So let us get into it. To start off with, why do we actually need to cry? Obviously, if we can do it, evolution tells us that it must have served a purpose. Before we talk about that, let's just briefly mention some of the anatomy for a second. Each of us is born with two teardocks in each of our eyes and they have two openings, one on the upper eyelid, one on the, like in the inner eyelid. You know what I'm talking about, close to the bridge of the nose. Now, crying doesn't just occur for emotional reasons.
那么让我们切入正题。首先，我们为什么真的需要哭泣？显而易见，如果我们能做到这一点，进化告诉我们它一定有某种用途。在我们讨论这个问题之前，让我们先简要介绍一下解剖学知识。我们每个人出生时，每只眼睛都有两个泪腺，它们有两个开口，一个在上眼皮，一个在内眼皮。你知道我在说什么，靠近鼻梁的地方。现在，哭泣并不只是出于情感原因。
There are actually three different types of tears. We have basal tears, reflex tears, and emotional tears. Basal tears, they wash away dirt and germs and yucky things, keeping us from getting an infection, going blind, that kind of thing. thing. Reflex tears are what occur when something harmful gets in our eye like a bug or when we're cutting onion. It's responsive to something coming from the environment. And then finally, we have emotional tears. Emotional tears are a lot more complicated than basal and reflex tears, which I'm sure we kind of all assumed at this point. But the thing about emotional tears is that they are not
实际上有三种不同类型的眼泪。我们有基础泪、反射泪和情感泪。基础泪可以冲洗掉灰尘、细菌和脏东西，防止我们感染、失明诸如此类的事情。反射泪是当有东西进入眼睛（如虫子）或我们切洋葱时产生的。它是对来自环境的事物的反应。最后，我们有情感泪。情感泪比基础泪和反射泪要复杂得多，我想我们此时此刻都有所体会。但情感泪的关键在于它们不是
automatic. In order to cry our limbic system, the part of our brain that regulates our emotions, that part of our brain has to be activated and send signals to our glands to produce tears. And in those tears contains a bunch of other proteins and hormones that we don't find in our everyday basal or reflex tears. Things like potassium, prolactin, which also helps us produce milk. And finally, the big one, stress hormones like cortisol. This is probably our first clue that we're dealing with something a little bit bigger when we need to cry. It's a lot more psychological than just physical. That's because most evolutionary researchers will tell you that crying serves a purpose. Actually, it serves a number of important functions that all have something to do with
自动的。为了哭泣，我们的边缘系统（大脑中调节情绪的部分）必须被激活，并向腺体发送信号以产生眼泪。这些眼泪中含有许多在日常基础泪或反射泪中找不到的其他蛋白质和荷尔蒙。例如钾、催乳素（它也有助于我们产生乳汁）。最后，最重要的一种是压力荷尔蒙，如皮质醇。这可能是我们的第一个线索，表明当我们想要哭泣时，我们正在处理一些更重大的事情。这在很大程度上是心理上的，而不仅仅是生理上的。这是因为大多数进化研究人员会告诉你，哭泣是有目的的。事实上，它具有许多重要的功能，这些功能都与
how we feel emotion and how we connect to others through mental, physical and emotional expressions of pain. So, firstly, when you are an emotional or physical pain, crying can actually make you feel really good. It can actually provide real physical relief from that pain. When you cry, your body releases hormones such as endorphins and oxytocin, the same chemical structures that we see in pain relievers and opioids. That is why a big sob feels just so good. Even though that might seem counterintuitive because we often associate it with sadness and pain,
我们如何感受情绪，以及我们如何通过痛苦的心理、生理和情感表达与他人建立联系有关。首先，当你处于情感或身体痛苦中时，哭泣实际上能让你感觉非常好。它实际上可以为这种痛苦提供真正的身体缓解。当你哭泣时，你的身体会释放内啡肽和催氧素等荷尔蒙，这与我们在止痛药和阿片类药物中看到的化学结构相同。这就是为什么大哭一场感觉如此美妙。尽管这可能有些反直觉，因为我们经常把哭泣与悲伤和痛苦联系在一起，
really this act is telling your body that something is wrong, something has triggered this reaction, and it needs to do something about it. So it fires up all these pleasurable neurotransmitters and hormones to counteract whatever painful thing is bothering us. There is a really interesting article by Harvard Health that talks about this, and it also speaks on how crying provides an emotional catharsis. It gives big emotions somewhere to go that isn't just running around in our brain in an endless ruminating loop. So it's really interesting because that is not a new idea, right?
实际上这种行为是在告诉你的身体，有什么地方不对劲了，有什么东西触发了这个反应，它需要为此做点什么。因此，它会启动所有这些带来快感的神经递质和荷尔蒙，来抵消任何困扰我们的痛苦事情。哈佛健康（Harvard Health）有一篇非常有趣的文章讨论了这一点，它还谈到了哭泣如何提供情感宣泄。它为强烈的情感提供了一个去处，而不是让它们在我们的脑海中无休止地反刍循环。所以这真的很有趣，因为这不是一个新想法，对吧？
Even back in a lot of the ancient civilizations, the Greeks, the Romans, they almost, they almost, saw our tears as having a healing capacity. They were, they would drain us of something negative. They would purify us. And not only has that really like continued to stand, but now there have been a lot more papers and a lot more research into this that is proving that those initial conceptions and ideas were actually pretty close to the scientific truth. Now, crying isn't the only way to do this, you know, exercise is another way. Displacement, as Freud would call it, is also another way taking your pain out on others. But it is the one that seems most accepted and socialized. Of course, if your pet died, you know, you're going to cry. People accept that as part of the sadness.
甚至早在许多古代文明中，希腊人、罗马人，他们几乎、几乎把我们的眼泪视为具有治愈能力。它们会排走我们身上消极的东西。它们会净化我们。不仅这种观点真正经受住了时间的考验，而且现在有更多的论文和更多的研究正在证明，最初的那些观念和想法实际上非常接近科学真理。现在，哭泣并不是做到这一点的唯一方法，你知道，锻炼是另一种方法。弗洛伊德称之为置换作用的机制也是另一种方法，把你的痛苦发泄在别人身上。但哭泣似乎是最被接受和社交化的方式。当然，如果你的宠物死了，你知道，你会哭。人们接受这是悲伤的一部分。
If someone yells at you, you have this really big emotional blowup or a conflict, again, it seems like the most natural reaction to a painful or uncomfortable situation. crying in this way can also have a self-soothing effect. So this was a finding published by a 2014 study that noticed when people cry, this very act also activated their parasympathetic nervous system, which helps us relax. And once again, we get that intense distress kind of out of the way through the act of crying. we, when we activate our parasympathetic nervous system, a whole bunch of other things occur in our body. Our heart rate begins to slow down, we begin to feel quite tired, and also all that emotion seems,
如果有人对你大喊大叫，你大发雷霆或发生冲突，同样，这似乎是对痛苦或不舒服情况的最自然反应。以这种方式哭泣还可以起到自我安慰的作用。这是2014年的一项研究发现的，该研究注意到，当人们哭泣时，这一行为本身也会激活他们的副交感神经系统，从而帮助我们放松。再一次，我们通过哭泣这一行为，将那种强烈的痛苦排解掉了。当我们激活副交感神经系统时，我们体内会发生一连串的其他变化。我们的心率开始减慢，我们开始感到相当疲倦，同时所有的情绪似乎也，
and that fear really seems to clear. So we're able to think more rationally and from a place of, I don't want to say peace, but from a place of calm. It's also why, after crying, you might feel really exhausted or drowsy, maybe even peaceful, you have involuntarily activated this very important part of your nervous system, but also you've drained a lot of that energy that was keeping you tense and sad and stressed. Now, there's been a bit of preliminary research that has suggested that crying, the reason why it makes us feel this way is because the very act of crying releases stress hormones
那种恐惧似乎真的烟消云散了。因此，我们能够进行更理性的思考，并从一个——我不想说平静，但从一个冷静的视角出发。这也是为什么在哭泣之后，你可能会感到筋疲力尽或昏昏欲睡，甚至感到平静，你不由自主地激活了神经系统中这个非常重要的部分，同时也消耗了大量让你感到紧张、悲伤和压力的能量。现在，有一些初步研究表明，哭泣之所以让我们有这种感觉，是因为哭泣这一行为本身可以通过产生眼泪来释放压力荷尔蒙
through the production of tears, meaning that there is less of that stress hormone, particularly cortisol to go around in the body. I'm going to like just, you know, I wanted to mention that, but I would also say that probably needs to be a bit more research. I don't really see how a few millimeters of tears can have that much impact on the stress response of a 60 kilo, 100 kilo, 150 kilo human. Like it seems quite negligible, but that is another explanation. And the final one as to why we cry has a lot to do with, um, our social evolution. So one of the first things that babies do when they are born is cry. Obviously, that's to get a lot of the fluid out of their lungs, but it's also to get attention.
，这意味着体内循环的压力荷尔蒙（特别是皮质醇）减少了。我只想，你知道，我顺便提一下，但我还得说，这可能需要更多的研究。我实在不明白几毫米的眼泪怎么会对一个60公斤、100公斤、150公斤的人类的应激反应产生那么大的影响。这似乎微不足道，但这是另一种解释。至于我们为什么哭泣的最后一点，在很大程度上与我们的社会进化有关。因此，婴儿出生后做的第一件事就是哭。显然，这是为了排出肺部的液体，但也是为了引起注意。
And then they pretty much don't stop crying ever. Like even as humans, we don't stop crying. But especially when we're babies, like, babies cry a whole lot. And the reason why is because crying is what we would call an attachment behavior. It serves. as a signal to those around us to comfort us. It draws people's attention to us because when they hear those cries, that automatically causes this association with distress. And that acknowledgement of distress activates the part of our brain that deals with empathy. And that is what motivates us to help someone to be pro-social. So crying in children and in adults promotes closeness. It promotes empathy in others.
然后他们几乎就再也停不下来不哭了。就像人类一样，我们不会停止哭泣。但特别是当我们还是婴儿的时候，婴儿会哭很多。原因在于哭泣是我们所说的依恋行为。它起到了。向周围人发出寻求安慰的信号的作用。它把人们的注意力吸引到我们身上，因为当他们听到这些哭声时，会自动将之与痛苦联系起来。对痛苦的认可激活了我们大脑中处理同理心的部分。这就是激励我们去帮助他人、变得亲社会的动力。因此，儿童和成人的哭泣能促进亲密感。它能促进他人的同理心。
It promotes kindness because it is intended evolutionarily, biologically, to elicit care and comfort. Actually, attachment theory, very, you know, the first attachment theory paper talks about the role of crying quite a bit. So back in the original studies conducted by John Bolby and Mary Ainsworth, they noticed that children who showed a lack of crying. when their parents left, when they were being comforted by a stranger or were left in a strange situation, those children whose immediate reaction was to not cry but to stay silent, they probably had a disorganized attachment style or an insecure, anxious, avoidant attachment style because they were used to this very innate and instinctual act of crying not being met with the typical response, you know, support, care and love. And so they almost just stopped doing it because they realized that
它能促进善良，因为从进化和生物学的角度来看，它旨在引发关怀和安慰。事实上，依恋理论，非常，你知道，第一篇依恋理论论文对哭泣的作用进行了不少讨论。所以在由约翰·鲍比（John Bowlby）和玛丽·安斯沃斯（Mary Ainsworth）最初进行的研讨中，他们注意到那些表现出不哭泣的孩子。当他们的父母离开时，当他们被陌生人安慰时或被留在陌生环境中时，那些直接反应不是哭泣而是保持沉默的孩子，他们可能表现出混乱型依恋风格或者不安全型焦虑-回避型依恋风格，因为他们习惯了这种非常先天和本能的哭泣行为没有得到典型的回应，你知道，支持、关怀和爱。所以他们几乎只是停止了哭泣，因为他们意识到
it didn't serve a function, the function that it should be serving, which is to, you know, receive empathy and receive care and kindness, not just from your primary caregiver, but from other people within our species around you. All right. So now that we've spoken about the functions and purposes of crying, what are some of the reasons that we can't do it? Why can't we cry? That's the real title of this episode. So let's start off with the first reason. Maybe you're just really happy. There is no reason at all why you can't cry. It's just that you have no reason to. That is actually a completely valid explanation for this. We're kind of all on this like very fun roller coaster of life. And sometimes you're just at a high point and you've stayed there for a few months. That is a good
它没有发挥作用，没有发挥它应该发挥的作用，也就是，你知道，获得同理心和关怀与善良，不仅来自你的主要照顾者，还来自你周围我们物种中的其他人。好了。既然我们已经讨论了哭泣的功能和目的，那么我们为什么做不到呢？为什么我们哭不出来？这才是这集节目的真正主题。让我们从第一个原因开始。也许你只是太快乐了。你哭不出来根本没有任何原因，只是你没有理由哭。这其实是一个完全合理解释。我们都在经历这个有趣的生活过山车。有时候你正处于人生的高峰，而且你在那里呆了几个月。这是件好事。
thing. I promise. But I get that sensation and anticipation of waiting for the other shoe to drop. I think if you're used to feeling like you're just someone who has bad luck or never feeling quite satisfied or happy and you're in this moment where everything just seems to be strangely going your way, it's natural to be feeling a little bit anxious about that and wondering what's wrong with you, wondering when this is all going to disappear. I want to give you permission right now. It's okay to just be happy and content for a while. But if you're not crying when it feels necessary, like after a traumatic event or something really
我保证。但我理解那种等待靴子落地的感觉和预期。我想，如果你习惯了觉得自己是个运气不好的人，或者从未感到十分满足或快乐，而你现在处于这样一个一切似乎都不可思议地顺心如意的时刻，那么对这种状态感到有点焦虑，想知道自己出了什么问题，想知道这一切什么时候会消失，是很自然的。我现在想给你许可。一段时间内保持快乐和满足是完全可以的。但如果你在感觉有必要哭泣的时候却没有哭，比如在经历了一次创伤性事件或个人生活中的重大打击之后，这可能是一个信号，说明你的斯多葛主义走得有点过头了，你可能在某种程度上与你的真实情感以及看似平静表面下正在发生的事情脱节了。如果你觉得这是哭泣的合适时机，却哭不出来，头号解释就是休克。在经历了一场丧亲之痛，甚至是分手之类的事情之后，我听到很多人说，这太奇怪了。就像，已经过去几天了，我完全没事。就像，我连一次都没哭过。
hard happening in your personal life, that is probably a sign that your stoicism is going a bit too far and you may be partially disconnected from your true emotions and what's going on underneath the seemingly composed surface. If it feels like an appropriate time to be crying and you can't, The number one explanation is shock. After a loss or even something like a breakup, I hear so many people saying, it's so strange. Like, it's been a few days and I'm completely fine. Like, I haven't cried once.
已经差不多三个星期了，我完全已经走出来了。你知道，这很可能不是真的。这并不是说你拥有超快速的情感治愈能力，也不是说你已经康复了。你真正经历的可能是休克。所以我们知道有几个。经历某些事情后我们必须经历的悲伤阶段，比如失落发生后。休克或否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。我认为抑郁阶段是
It's been like three weeks and I'm totally already over it. You know, that is just not probably true. That's not a sign that you just have super quick emotional healing powers or that you've already recovered. What you're actually experiencing is probably shock. So we know that there are a few. stages of grief that we go through after something, after a loss, after something happens. Shock or denial, anger, bargaining, depression and acceptance. And the depression stage is what I think
我们大多数人在想到心碎或失去时所想到的。它是外在的，是充满感觉的，是高度可视且情绪化的，可能甚至伴随着泪水。但在我们到达那里之前，我们还有三个阶段要经历，这些阶段并不总是伴随着那么多的泪水。休克是最显著的一个。这是我们的大脑在经历强烈、改变人生或痛苦的事情的直接后果时所采取的一种保护或防御机制，它帮助我们把情绪进行心理隔离，直到我们准备好或拥有足够的精神资源或心理空间去处理它们。所以这背后是有进化原因的。当年我们在撒哈拉大草原漫游时，我们要躲避野兽和狮子，还要与邻居交战。
most of us think when we think about heartbreak or loss. It's very outward, it's very feeling, it's very visible and emotional, it's probably even teary. But before we get there, we have three other stages to pass through that don't always involve as many tears. Shock is the most significant one. It is a protective or defensive mechanism our brain enlists in the immediate aftermath of something intense or life-changing or painful that helps us compartmentalize emotions until we are prepared or have the mental resources or the mental space to deal with them. So there's an evolutionary reason for this. Back in the day when we roamed the Sahara, we were fleeing wild beasts and lions and warring with our neighbors. we sometimes had to delay an emotional reaction until we were out of danger.
有时我们不得不推迟情感反应，直到我们脱离危险。因为当时沉重的负面情绪可能会让我们付出生命的代价。它会分散我们逃跑的注意力，让我们无法从危险的这种处境中脱身。这种为了生存而本能地回避最初那些艰难、沉重情绪的本能，一直伴随着我们。所以现在它表现为对各种更现代的触发因素的反应，比如分手。你的大脑正试图通过将这些情绪和感觉几乎关在心理玻璃墙后面，来尽可能长时间地保护你。我们可以看到发生了什么。我们可以看到这会带来痛苦，但全部的冲击还没有到来。也可能是因为你知道，
Because heavy emotions during that time could really cost us our lives. It would take our attention off of escaping, off of getting away from a dangerous situation. And this instinct to avoid initially hard, heavy emotions for survival purposes, has carried with us. And so now it's seen in response to different more modern triggers, like a breakup. Your brain is trying to keep you safe for as long as it can by keeping those emotions and feelings almost like behind a mental wall of glass. We can see what happened. We can see that it's going to hurt, but the full impact hasn't hit us yet. It may also be that you know how,
你终于让自己去感受你所经历的一切时会有多难。所以你正在尽最大努力，无论是有意识还是无意识地，拖延这个不可避免的结果。即使这并非完全是有意识的，你所做的事情也是在陷入一种妄想，即推迟艰难的情感可能意味着它们永远不会真正发生。所以当这堵墙倒塌时——你可能不想听到这个，但它终究会倒塌的。可能是几天，可能是几周，可能是几个月，甚至几年。那就是我们开始看到我们最习以为常的痛苦显现出来的时候。
you know how hard it's going to be when you finally let yourself feel what you've been through. So you are trying your hardest unconsciously, even consciously, to delay the inevitable. Even if this isn't entirely conscious, what you're doing is buying into the delusion that putting off hard feelings may mean that they never actually occur. So when the wall comes down and you may not want to hear this, but it will eventually come down. It could be days, it could be weeks, it could be months, even years. that's when we see the suffering we're most accustomed to seeing begin.
有趣的是，往往触发我们眼泪的事情，通常与我们悲伤和痛苦最初的或预计的根源完全无关。我们可以花上几个月的时间处于完全的情感停滞和麻木状态。然后在一个星期一，一个普通的星期一，你错过了公交车，你的衣服穿着不舒服，天气稍微有点太热，然后你踢到了脚趾，水龙头就被打开了，所有那些积攒了数月的负面情绪如潮水般涌入你的生活，只需要那根压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，那些日常小事的压力叠加在所有其他
The interesting thing is that more often than not, the thing that finally triggers our tears is normally completely unrelated to the initial or predicted source of our sadness and our misery. We can spend like months in a state of just like complete emotional stagnation and numbness. And then one Monday, a random Monday, you miss your bus, your outfit, uncomfortable it's just a little bit too hot and then you stab your toe and the tap just gets turned on and all of those months of pent up emotion flood into your life all it took was for that metaphorical straw to break the camel's back that daily stress of that small thing on top of all of the other
重大生活事件之上，终于提供了一个释放的出口。这感觉有点不公平，我懂，但是有时候大脑、心思和我们的心理并不按照我们的规则和意愿运作。与此同时，你可能无法触及内心深处那个真正想要针对某种情况大哭一场的自己。你可能难以应对这种情况的另一个原因是药物，特别是抗抑郁药和SSRI，即选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂。人们对此进行过研究。
major life events to finally provide a release it feels a little bit unfair I I know, but sometimes the brain and our mind and our psychology doesn't operate according to our rules and what we want. In the meantime, you may not be able to tap into that side of you that really does just want to have a big cry in response to whatever it is. Another reason why you might be struggling with this a reaction is because of medication, specifically antidepressants and SSRI, so selective serotonin re-uptake inhibitors. They've done studies on this.
这是服用抗抑郁药最大的副作用之一，46%服用这类药物的人。会经历情感迟钝。尽管这些药物非常神奇，它们有助于缓解可能导致完全功能失调的抑郁和焦虑症状，但它们也会影响我们体验日常情感的方式。所以我以前在节目中谈过这个。
It's one of the biggest side effects of being on antidepressants, 46% of people who are on these. Experience, blunted emotions. And although these medications are amazing, they help relieve symptoms of depression, anxiety that have maybe caused complete dysfunction. They can also affect how we experience everyday feelings. So I've talked about this before on the show.
我服用Lexapro三年了。在那段时间里，我哭的次数绝对不超过两次。而在那期间，我经历了一次严肃的、长期的分手。我的祖父去世了。我的个人生活中还发生了许多其他的事情。我就是做不到。真的，无论我多么努力，我都无法流下一滴眼泪。这真的很奇怪，因为我有其他所有想哭的迹象。
I was on Lexapro for three years. I don't think I cried more than twice over that period of time. And during that time, I went through a serious, like, long-term breakup. My grandfather passed away. A lot of other things were happening in my personal life. And I just couldn't do. I literally, no matter how hard I tried, I could not shed a tear. And it was really strange because I had all the other signs that I wanted to.
我的胸口感到紧绷。我的喉咙感到肿胀。我的额头感到紧张。感觉它就要发生了。我几乎就要成功了。然后它就在临界点戛然而止。那种感觉太没有成就感了。在更严重的时候，
I had this tightness in my chest. I had this swelling in my throat. I had this tension in my forehead. It felt like it was going to happen. I was almost there. And then it would stop right short of like a tear. And it was so unfulfilling. And in more serious moments,
它实际上确实让人觉得情绪在体内停留的时间更长了，因为它们无处可去。有时这使得它们更难控制。这使得它们，某种程度上让人觉得它们从未真正。消失，而是一直以较低的频率在背景中存在。我和治疗师谈论这件事时用的比方是，当家里飞进一只苍蝇，你总是抓不到它，虽然它不是那么烦人，但还是挺让人心烦的，你只想除掉它。你只想拍死那只苍蝇。你只想
it actually did feel like the emotions lingered longer in my body because they had nowhere to go. And that at times made them harder to manage. It made it, it kind of made it seem like they never truly. went away, but they were kind of just always there at a lower frequency in the background. The way that I was talking to my therapist about it was when you have a fly buzzing around your house and you just can't quite catch it and it's not that annoying, but it's still pretty annoying and you just want to get rid of it. You just want to smash that fly. You just want to
进行那种宣泄性的动作。我知道这和我谈过的许多其他服用这些药物的人有着共同的体验。这有点像你被迫做出的权衡。你想保持正常功能，不被焦虑或抑郁情绪压垮吗？那就意味着有时你必须放弃像以前那样深度、强烈地感受事物的能力。这是一个我们需要单独做出的决定。这并不意味着它就不痛苦，也没有那些时候——当你真的希望自己能够调用所有那些情感、你的全部敏感度和感受力，以及那个你可以汲取的能量源泉时。说到治疗抑郁症的药物，我们也许还应该
have that cathartic action. I know this is a common experience for a lot of other people I've spoken to who are on these medications. And it's kind of like you're forced into this trade-off. Do you want to be able to function and not be overwhelmed by anxiety or depressive thoughts? That's going to mean that sometimes you have to give up your ability to feel as deeply and as intensely as you previously have. And it's a decision that we need to make individually. It doesn't mean that it's not still difficult and there aren't times when you really wish that you had access to all that emotion, your full range of sensitivity and feeling, and just that energy source that you can tap into. Speaking of medications for depression, we should also probably
关注一下这些病情本身对我们哭泣能力的影响。所以我想关于抑郁症的一个常见误解是，你一直在痛哭，你总是一汪泪水。实际上，有时你是如此悲伤和绝望，以至于你根本哭不出来。这被称为忧郁型抑郁症。你对所有的情绪完全且彻底地麻木了。在这种平淡的情绪状态下，并不是说你甚至感受不到美好的事物。你什么都感受不到。包括悲伤，因为没有任何东西，甚至是糟糕的事物、艰难的事物、痛苦的事物，对你来说都不再有意义。现在，我要说这是一种非常罕见的情况，但它确实还会发生，如果你认为它适用于你，那就值得对此做进一步的调查。
focus on the impact of those conditions as well on our ability to cry. So I think one of the common misconceptions about being depressed is that you are constantly sobbing, you're constantly a pool of tears. Actually, sometimes you are so sad and forlorn, you just can't cry. This is known as depression with melancholia. You are completely and entirely numb to all your emotions. And in that flat, emotional state, it's not that you just can't even feel the good things. You can't feel anything. Sadness included, because nothing, not even the bad things, the hard things, the painful things have meaning to you anymore. Now, I would say this is a is super rare, but it does still occur and it's worth going further with your investigation
这显然是我们体验情感方式的重大改变，因此你需要去看心理医生，因为他们能够真正告诉你更多关于导致这种状况的原因，以及如何摆脱这种完全的精神麻木和陈腐状态的信息。现在，让我们继续谈谈人们在想到无法哭泣时最常想到的原因。我把它留到了最后。情感压抑。这是一种无意识的行为，将我们认为危险的或过度的感觉压下去。人们用不同的方式处理情绪。我们可以尊重这一点。悲伤、哀痛、愤怒，无论它可能是什么，心碎，它们的体验都不是千篇一律的。有些人有
into this if you think it applies. This is obviously a significant change in how we experience emotions and therefore you will need to talk to a therapist because they're going to be able to really tell you a lot more about what creates this situation and kind of how to get out of this complete mental numbness and staleness. Now, let's move on and talk about the reason most people think of when it comes to an inability to cry. I saved it for last. Emotional repression. The unconscious act of pushing down feelings that we see as dangerous or too much. People deal with emotions in different ways. We can respect that. Sadness, grief, anger, whatever it may be heartbreak, they are not a one-size-fits-all experience. Some people have
非常外向的风格。他们非常容易且频繁地哭泣。通常这些人更加敏感。他们更有同理心。他们被社会化为更能接受眼泪和哭泣作为管理情绪的方式。这也可能归结于诸如睡眠较少等因素。他们有我们刚才谈到的潜在抑郁症状。所有这些只会使我们更容易哭泣，有时甚至毫无原因。然而，另一些人则更加压抑，他们发现。很难哭泣，也很难通过这种方法表达内心正在发生的事情。然后还有这样一类人，他们可能会刻意压抑自己的情绪，以避免向自己（而不仅仅是向他人）暴露他们的感受。通常在压抑的情绪下，你甚至可能没有意识到你在
a very expressive style. They cry very easily and frequently. Often these people are more sensitive. They have more empathy. They've been socialized to be more accepting of tears and crying as a way to manage emotions. It may also come down to factors like they sleep less. They have underlying depressive symptoms like we spoke about. All of these just make us more prone to crying, sometimes for no reason. Other people though are more repressed and they find it really. hard to cry and to express what's going on through this method. And then there's this category of people who may intentionally suppress their emotions to avoid revealing to themselves, not just to others, what they're feeling. Frequently with repressed emotions, you might not even realize you're
无意识地回避自己的感受，这就是为什么你会对自己的哭泣无能为力感到困惑。那是因为这种无能的根源发生在很久以前，通常是在过去的童年经历中。可能是这种情况：在你的家庭或文化中，大肆表现悲伤甚至快乐是不被接受的。它们被认为是不合适的。因此，当你产生冲动时，你一次又一次地被条件反射去压抑而不是去感受。可能每当你哭泣时，你是在表达对情绪的敏感，你却因此受到了惩罚。于是你开始将这种需要感受的需求与惩罚、痛苦和羞耻联系起来。我们在男性身上经常看到这一点。
unconsciously avoiding your feelings, which is why you might be confused by your inability to cry. That is because the origins of this inability happened a long time ago, often in the past, in our childhood experiences. It could be the case that big displays of sadness, even happiness, were not accepted in your family or culture. They weren't seen as appropriate. And so when you have the urge, you have been conditioned time and time again to suppress rather than feel. It may have been that every time you did cry, you were expressing sensitivity towards your emotions, you were punished for it. And so you have begun to associate the need to feel with punishment and pain and shame. We see this a lot with men.
社会不断地告诉他们，这不够男子气概，或者不合适，或者这不是男孩应有的行为。因此，他们内化了这些外部态度，以至于他们对女性的门槛。你知道的，无论什么需要眼泪的要求，都会高得多。甚至当他们真的，你知道，当真正艰难的事情发生时，他们也无法让自己进入这种状态，因为他们太习惯于压抑这种冲动了。这背后的羞耻感也造成了我们与情感之间的脱节。我很幸运。我有一个比我母亲还爱哭的父亲，但很多人确实是从与自己同性别的父母那里学习如何处理情绪的。我真的很幸运。我觉得我在一个总是能接受这一点的家庭中长大。对于眼泪有一种
Society continuously tells them it's not manly or appropriate or how boys should behave. And so they internalize those external attitudes such that their threshold for women. what's, you know, whatever demands tears, it's much higher. And even when they really, you know, when things that really hard happen, they cannot get themselves into this state because they are so used to suppressing this urge. And it carries a lot of shame that also creates a disconnect between us and our emotions. I was lucky. I had a father who probably cries more than my mother, but a lot of people do learn how to process their emotions from the parent who is the same gender as them. I was really lucky. I feel like I grew up in a family who that was always accepted. There was a
自然的反应，有时我对那些没有这样一个榜样，没有在一个充满情感接受的环境中被社会化和抚养长大的人感到非常难过。正如我之前所说，我们拥有哭泣的能力是有原因的，它可以提供宣泄、释放，作为一种社交信号，当人们沮丧、需要我们帮助时注意到他们。当你被迫剥夺自己的一些情绪功能（如哭泣）时，其他事情也往往会失衡。有迹象表明，所有这些情感都会转移到其他地方，并以更有害的方式表达出来，比如通过愤怒和暴怒，因为它需要一个去处。我认为这
natural reaction to tears and I sometimes feel quite sad for people who didn't have this as an example who weren't socialized and raised in an environment of emotional acceptance. As I said before, we have the ability to cry for a reason to provide release, catharsis, as a social cue to notice when people are upset when they need our help. When you are forced to deprive yourself of some emotional function like crying, other things also tend to go off balance. There's suggestions that all that feeling goes elsewhere and it's expressed in more harmful ways like through rage and anger because it needs somewhere to go. And I think that you. think that's a lesson to all of us that suppression and avoidance of emotions, it doesn't mean that
对我们所有人都是一个教训，即压抑和回避情绪，并不意味着它们不存在，它们不会停止存在。它们会找到某种方式浮出水面，无论你是否愿意，它们都会找到方法来引起你的注意。因此，我们已经讨论了我们无法哭泣的主要原因，但我们究竟该怎么做呢？我们不会就此罢休。接下来的路该怎么走？是去看尽可能多的悲伤电影或动物救援视频，直到有什么东西触动心弦吗？大概不会。当我们触及问题的根源时，我们实际上需要从眼泪中退后一步，看看这一切背后的东西——与你更深层情感状态的脱节。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可坐时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。
they don't exist, that they cease to exist. They will find a way to come to the surface. They will find a way to get your attention whether you want them to or not. So we've discussed the main reasons for our inability to cry, but what do we actually do about it? We're not going to leave it there. What is the way forward here? Is it to watch as many sad movies as possible or animal rescue videos and like wait until something clicks. Probably not. When we're getting to the root of this, we actually need to take a step back from the tears and look what's underneath it all, a disconnect with your deeper emotional state. So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO percent 在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得
available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when
黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMAs 上双击了莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。什么？乔治·布什跟莉儿·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回望过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克毒品。
Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的事，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我在心理健康领域的个人经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我采访了。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Or are you a good person because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要。还是你做个好人是因为你害怕。因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app.
那是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难成长》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了测试数据。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格（一个女同性恋者）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When it comes to an inability to cry, The solution is not forcing yourself to cry by any means necessary.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是“爱情陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，来自美利哥帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。当无法哭泣时，解决方案绝不是通过一切必要手段强迫自己哭泣。
It's not like you have a blocked drain or a pipe. And once you remove the gunk, everything will start flowing freely again. And you're not a plumbing problem. The solution is getting back in touch with what you're feeling when you're feeling it. It's about a deeper emotional disconnect that we need to heal. So let's talk about it. If you've been through a few hard chapters recently or you have been once, as we said, you know, conditioned or socialized, to repress rather than express, your ability to identify your
这不像你的下水道或管道堵塞了。一旦你清除了污垢，一切就会再次顺畅流动。你也不是一个管道问题。解决方案是重新去感受当你感受到某种情绪时的本来面目。这关乎我们需要治愈的更深层次的情感断层。所以我们来聊聊这个。如果你最近经历了一些艰难的篇章，或者正如我们所说的那样，你曾经被（某种程度上的）条件反射或社会化，习惯于压抑而不是表达，那么你识别自己
emotions and what is bothering you has probably become a little bit disorganized or broken. When we see emotions as our captors or as a source of shame, or we perceive them as being stronger than us, that is when we have an incentive to not feel them at all, and that results in that inability for expression and release. To get past this, we can do a few. things and I'm going to talk about three strategies in particular, noticing your emotions in your body, talking to your friends about their feelings and finding a creative outlet. Paying attention to your body is so important when it comes to noticing and making peace with whatever is going on in your mind. We feel emotions in the body. This has been written about so much in the last few decades,
情绪以及困扰你的事情的能力可能已经变得有点混乱或受损了。当我们把情绪视为我们的枷锁、羞耻的来源，或者认为它们比我们更强大时，我们就会产生不去感受它们的动机，而这就会导致无法表达和释放。为了克服这一点，我们可以做一些事情，我将具体谈谈三个策略：在身体中注意你的情绪，和你的朋友谈论他们的感受，以及寻找一个创造性的发泄方式。当涉及到注意和接受你心中发生的一切时，关注你的身体是极其重要的。我们在身体中感受情绪。在过去的几十年里，关于这方面的文章已经很多了，
perhaps most notably in the book, The Body Keeps the Score, which mainly talks about how stress and trauma in particular have a somatic form and a somatic impact. It causes chronic pain, hormone imbalance, so much more. On a smaller scale, though, every emotion we feel, we feel it through our neurons. Now, a lot of us think that neurons are only found in the brain. It's a common misconception, but it's actually not true. Neurons are found throughout the body. outside of the brain they're known as sensory and motor neurons. And our brain is in control of all of these. It is the main communicator.
其中最著名的可能是《身体记得这一切》这本书，它主要探讨了压力和特别是创伤是如何具有躯体形式和躯体影响的。它会导致慢性疼痛、荷尔蒙失调等等。不过，在一个较小的范围内，我们感受到的每一种情绪，都是通过神经元感受到的。现在，我们很多人认为神经元只存在于大脑中。这是一个常见的误解，但它实际上是不正确的。神经元遍布全身。在大脑之外，它们被称为感觉神经元和运动神经元。我们的大脑控制着所有这一切。它是主要的沟通者。
It is the leader. The other thing our brain is in control of communicating with is our emotions. And so there is this connection between what we feel emotionally and what we feel physically because it is using a lot of the same pathways. A lot of those pathways are connected. What that means is that when we begin to use physical cues to notice and identify our feelings, we can really unlock a whole new range of emotions and emotional recognition we didn't previously have. For example, anger is often felt between the chest and the head,
它是领导者。我们大脑控制沟通的另一件事是我们的情绪。因此，我们在情感上的感受和身体上的感受之间存在着这种联系，因为它使用了许多相同的通路。其中许多通路是相连的。这意味着，当我们开始使用身体线索来注意和识别我们的感受时，我们真的可以开启一系列我们以前没有的全新情绪和情感识别。例如，愤怒通常在胸部和头部之间感受到，
whilst fear is usually felt between the stomach and the chest. Sadness is felt in the face, in the throat, even in our limbs, it makes them heavy. And emotional pain can really be felt all over. A lot of us have become very disconnected from these signs and emotional cues that are present in our limbs and in our muscles and in our bones. If you're struggling with emotional expression, tap into what you're feeling through a body scan. And how you do that is you focus on each area of your body from your toes to the top of your head and you pay attention. What is causing you discomfort? Where is their heaviness or tightness? Where is their pent-up energy and excitement and like tingling? And what is that trying to tell? What is that?
而恐惧通常在胃和胸部之间感受到。悲伤则体现在面部、喉咙，甚至四肢中，这会让它们变得沉重。情感上的痛苦真的可以随处感受到。我们很多人已经与存在于我们的四肢、肌肉和骨骼中的这些信号和情感线索失去了联系。如果你在情感表达方面苦苦挣扎，那就通过身体扫描来挖掘你的感受。具体做法是，从脚趾到头顶，关注你身体的每一个部位并保持注意。是什么让你感到不适？哪里有沉重感或紧绷感？哪里有压抑的能量、兴奋和类似刺痛的感觉？这究竟是在试图传达什么？那是什么？
you. Those sensations are not there by accident. That is your brain trying to communicate something to you that you may have previously stopped yourself from recognizing because you are trying to compartmentalize and protect yourself. As you do that body scan, consciously tense and then relax your muscles, particularly your face and your shoulders. Now, I sometimes do this when I'm trying to fall asleep and when I consciously turn my attention to these parts of my body, it's really only then that I realized just how much just like tension and like anxiety and stress is being stored in those areas. If you can, you should do it right now. Let all of those muscles relax. Let all of that tension in your shoulders go for a second and then try it again. Let them go even looser and try your
你。这些感觉并非偶然出现。那是你的大脑试图向你传达一些东西，而你以前可能为了分流和保护自己而阻止自己去识别。在进行身体扫描时，有意识地绷紧然后放松你的肌肉，尤其是你的面部和肩膀。现在，有时我在试图入睡时会这样做，当我把注意力有意识地转移到身体的这些部位时，真的只有在那时我才意识到这些区域储存了多少紧张、焦虑和压力。如果可以的话，你现在就应该这样做。放松所有这些肌肉。让肩膀上的所有紧张感释放一秒钟，然后再试一次。让它们变得更放松，然后试试你的
forehead. Drop it as a low as you can. I'm literally doing it as I'm speaking right now. Feel how your eyebrows move closer to your eyes. Feel how everything around your skull just seems to loosen. You might even get like a little tingle. And can you notice just how much better you feel? And can you also pay attention to what's coming up for you? That is really the first step in this process. Observing and discerning how emotions are sitting in your body and what different emotions feel like for you. Secondly, talk to your friends about their feelings. When we are disconnected from our emotions, sometimes we no longer have the words to explain what we're feeling. And that's where talking to people you trust can be so helpful.
额头。尽量把它放低。我说话的时候 literally 就在这么做。感受你的眉毛是如何靠近眼睛的。感受你头骨周围的一切是如何变得松弛的。你甚至可能会有点刺痛感。你能注意到你感觉好多了吗？你还能注意到自己内心涌现出了什么吗？这确实是这个过程的第一步。观察和辨别情绪是如何驻留在你的身体里，以及不同的情绪对你来说是什么感觉。其次，和你的朋友谈谈他们的感受。当我们与情绪断开联系时，有时我们不再有词汇来解释我们的感受。这就是为什么和信任的人交谈会如此有帮助。
Not only do I think they give us a lot of language for what we're going through, which I always find super helpful. They also offer support and a place for vulnerability, a space for openness that maybe we just haven't had before. We've never been permitted access to. I think one of the crazy things that always comes up for me is just this constant epiphany that you are not the only one. Nothing is experienced in isolation. So much of what we experience in our 20s and beyond is universal. And it's made a lot easier with community and support. And someone who is going to sit across from you and say, I'm witnessing your life. I see what you're going through. That is really, really hard.
不仅我认为他们为我们正在经历的事情提供了很多语言，我总是觉得这超级有用。他们还提供支持和脆弱的空间，提供一种我们以前可能从未有过的开放空间。我们从来没有获得过这种准入权限。我认为总是让我感到疯狂的一件事情就是这种持续的顿悟：你不是唯一的一个。没有任何体验是孤立的。我们在20多岁及以后经历的很多事情都是普遍的。有了社群和支持，这一切就会变得容易得多。当有人坐在你对面说：“我见证了你的生活。我看到了你正在经历的事情。这真的，真的很艰难。”
hearing someone else say that validates so much of what we're experiencing. I have had that happen where just someone says like, I'm so sorry, I can see that must be so painful. And just that acknowledgement like makes me burst into tears. I think become really curious about other people's emotions as well. Ask questions. Listen, other people crave to be heard as much as you do. and in response, share your own feelings. You know, as humans, we have this beautiful superpower that we can connect through emotions and through vulnerability.
听到别人这么说，证实了我们正在经历的很多事情。我就经历过这种事，当时有人说：“我很抱歉，我看得出来这一定很痛苦。”仅仅是这种承认就让我泪流满面。我认为也要对其他人的情绪保持强烈的好奇心。问问题。倾听，别人和您一样渴望被倾听。作为回应，分享你自己的感受。你知道，作为人类，我们有一个美丽的超能力，那就是我们可以通过情感和脆弱性建立联系。
And as we get better at being vulnerable with other people, we get better at being vulnerable with ourselves, having a sense of acceptance that this is okay, this is normal, other people are experiencing this. I am not defective. I am not faulty. There is nothing wrong with me. And the tears might not come instantly. But there is this incredible.
随着我们越来越擅长向其他人展现脆弱，我们就越能更好地对自己展现脆弱，并有一种接受感：这是可以的，这是正常的，其他人也在经历这一切。我不是残缺的。我不是有毛病的。我没有问题。眼泪可能不会马上流出来。
level of acceptance and this increased level of recognition for what you are actually experiencing. And there's just this increased level of just kindness in your life, which I think everyone can really benefit from. Finally, look for an outlet, especially one that is creative. There is no one way to feel. I feel like I have mentioned that a million times in this episode. There are so many other ways we can channel what's happening in our bodies, firstly, but also in our minds into something that is tangible and it doesn't have to involve tears or crying.
但会有这种令人难以置信的接受水平，并且对你实际正在经历的事情有更高的认知水平。你的生活中也会多出一层单纯的善良，我认为每个人都能从中真正受益。最后，寻找一个宣泄口，尤其是富有创造力的那种。感受的方式不止一种。我觉得我在这一集中已经提到过一百万次了。我们还有很多其他的方法，可以把我们身体里（首先）以及头脑中正在发生的事情，引导成有形的东西，而且这不一定非要涉及到眼泪或哭泣。
When that thing that we choose to use as our outlet is creative or physical, it also allows us to use these parts of our brain that we may otherwise be neglecting or just not using as much. It makes us feel less inhibited. It frees parts of us that otherwise have nowhere else to exist. that is the power of of creativity. And I've talked about this on the podcast before, but after my first big breakup, I tried anything creative or with my hands that I could.
当我们选择作为发泄口的东西具有创造性或身体活动性时，它还允许我们使用大脑中其他地方可能被忽视或没有被充分使用的部分。它让我们感觉没那么拘束。它释放了我们身上那些原本无处可去的部位。这就是创造力的力量。我在播客里谈过这个，但在我的第一次重大分手之后，我尝试了任何有创意的或需要动手做的事情。
I did painting, I did pottery. I even did weaving for a while. It's not as fun as you think. It takes ages. But it just felt like my brain was opening up and noticing a whole new world, both externally and within. There is a reason why art therapy is so popular
我画过画，做过陶艺。我甚至还织过一段时间的毛衣。它没有你想的那么有趣。需要花好长时间。但它给我的感觉就像我的大脑正在敞开，注意到一个全新的世界，无论是在外部还是在内心。艺术疗法如此受欢迎是有原因的
because we are finally waking up to the fact that doing something purposeful and meaningful and artistic and creating something rather than always feeling like the world is taking things from us. It helps us regulate what we're feeling. Our emotions are a huge source of inspiration and they want a place to go there looking for an outlet and maybe right now that's not crying for you but I think the more you, the further you get in this process, the more everything else seems to loosen up. If you want some further evidence of this as a really well-known UCL study that was conducted in part with BBC Arts. And what they found was that when they gave people the space to be creative, especially in response to big, large, scary
因为我们终于意识到，做一些有目的、有意义、艺术性的事情，去创造一些东西，而不是总觉得世界在从我们这里夺走东西。这有助于我们调节我们的情绪。我们的情绪是灵感的巨大源泉，它们希望有个去处，正在寻找一个发泄口，也许现在对你来说那不是哭泣，但我认为你在这一过程中走得越远，其他一切似乎就越放松。如果你想了解这方面的更多证据，伦敦大学学院（UCL）曾做过一项非常著名的研究，该研究是与英国广播公司艺术频道（BBC Arts）联合进行的。他们发现，当他们给人们提供发挥创造力的空间时，特别是在应对巨大、可怕的
emotions, it didn't actually matter if they were even objectively good at it. It was just the participation in the act that counted. Make bad art. Express everything and anything. And you will slowly see how your access to your emotions becomes expanded because you, you know, you you begin to see them in a positive light as a source of inspiration and motivation and of creativity. Finally, I say this in a lot of these episodes because I just think it's so true. Be gentle with yourself. Imagine that the person sitting in front of you who is struggling with their emotions with their ability to cry is five-year-old you.
情绪时，他们客观上画得好不好其实并不重要。参与这个行为本身才是最重要的。创作糟糕的艺术。表达一切。你会慢慢发现，你获取情绪的途径变得更加宽广了，因为你（你知道的）开始以一种积极的眼光来看待它们，将它们视为灵感、动力和创造力的源泉。最后，我在很多节目中都说过这句话，因为我真的觉得它是如此真实。对你自己好一点。想象一下，坐在你面前这个正苦于无法处理情绪、无法哭泣的人，就是五岁的你自己。
You wouldn't yell at them. You wouldn't shame them. You wouldn't get angry at them. I know it's frustrating. I know sometimes we just long for that catharsis. and release of a good old-fashioned cry. But you are not defective, you are not faulty, you are not a psychopath because that isn't available to you at the moment.
你不会对他们大喊大叫。你不会羞辱他们。你不会对他们发脾气。我知道这很令人沮丧。我知道有时我们只是渴望那种老式哭泣所带来的宣泄和释放。
There are so many reasons and very valid explanations for why this is. But there are also so many ways through. You are doing the best you can. You're probably managing a lot in your life right now and your brain is trying to help you in some way. but I often find when we finally get to a place of feeling emotionally safe and secure, the tears will come. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode.
但这背后有太多的原因和非常合理的解释。但也有很多应对的方法。你已经尽力了。你现在的生活中可能要应付很多事情，你的大脑在某种程度上正试图帮助你。但我经常发现，当我们最终到达一个感到情绪安全和稳妥的地方时，眼泪就会夺眶而出。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。
I hope you got something out of it. I hope that you enjoyed it. I hope that you learned something from my experience. You know, that's always the mission with these episodes is being like, you know, your 20s feel super isolating. I'm there with you. You're not alone. There are so many people who are going through.
希望你从中有所收获。希望你喜欢它。希望你从我的经历中学到了东西。你知道，这些节目的宗旨始终是：“你知道的，20多岁时会感到超级孤立。我和你在一起。你并不孤单。有这么多人正在经历
something similar. As always, if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify. Wherever you are listening, I, you know, I don't know if people really know this. It's kind of just me running this podcast. I don't really have like a huge team. So I'm still the one who reads all of your messages and all of your reviews and all of your comments and it really makes my day. So also if you have an episode suggestion, I say this at the end of every episode. Please feel free to DM me at That Psychology Podcast. I would love to hear what you have in mind.
类似的事情。”像往常一样，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、声田（Spotify）上留下五星好评。无论你在哪里收听，我（你知道的）不知道人们是否真的知道这一点。这个播客基本上是我一个人在运营。我其实没有什么庞大的团队。所以我仍然是那个阅读你们所有的私信、所有的评价和所有的评论的人，这真的让我的一天都变得美好了。所以，如果你有什么节目建议，我每集结束时都会说这句话。请随时在Instagram上私信我 @That Psychology Podcast。我很想听听你的想法。
And if you want to see what I'm doing in my own life as a 20-something-year-old, feel free to follow me at Jemma Speg on Instagram. And we will be back on Friday with a new episode. Until then, stay safe, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
如果你想看看我作为一个二十几岁的年轻人过着怎样的生活，欢迎在Instagram上关注我 @Jemma Speg。我们将在周五带着新的一集回归。在此之前，请保持安全，我们很快会聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hand. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即“TWO percent”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在“Look Back at it”播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会邀请你来到这里，剖析过去发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何与我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家一起挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest, conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does
在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“look back at it”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不
not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the iHeard radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an iHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
意味着你需要这么做。在iHeart radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the hard way》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是由人类创作的。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。